これは、キルドのレストランで働くケンスケの一日です。
ケンスケは
毎日 7 時半に起き、朝食にトーストと卵を食べ、
歯を磨きます。
ウェイターの制服を着て、自転車に乗って、
有名なレストランへ働きます。
ホモ・パイカー・ウナギ レストランに着くと、
ここから朝のミーティングに参加し、客の準備をする。
冷凍庫から食べ物を取り出し、
味噌汁の材料を準備し
、
前の晩の10時にダイニングエリアにゴミが落ちていないかチェックする。
30 ドアが開き、ケンスケの本格的な
仕事が始まります、このレストランは
とても
おしゃれです、ごめんなさい、
英語のメニューと日本語のメニューはどちらがいいですか、ああ英語で失礼してください、うわー、ケンスケは
もう本当に忙しいので、
注文しても大丈夫ですか、わかりました、はい、します うなぎ
セットをどうぞ、いいですか、ああ、
私もお願いします、いつも忙しいですか、すみません、5時5分のテーブルはありますか、ごめんなさい、お待ちください、そうそう、ごめんなさい、行ってもいいですか、はい、ついて来てください、ああ、
ありがとう、たくさん
注文してください、言い訳します お待ちください、
ごめんなさい、
英語で話していました、いいですね、こんにちは、ごめんなさい、
英語のメニューを頼んだのですが、
日本語のメニューがありました、わかりました、
頑張ってください、
ケンスケ